the bottom line is we must write so that
our readers will pay attention and be
engaged today we will learn how to
become better writers for busy
readers my name is Matt Abrahams and I
teach strategic communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business
welcome to think fast talk smart the
podcast today I really look forward to
speaking with Todd rers Todd is a
professor of public policy at the
Harvard Kennedy School of government and
is the faculty director of the
behavioral insights group Todd teaches
courses on the science of behavior
change and he has written a new book
called writing for busy readers
communicate more effectively in the real
world Todd when you and I first got a
chance to speak a while back I felt like
I was with a kindred spirit we both have
such a passion for communication thanks
for being here I'm super excited to chat
with you thanks for having me Matt so
let's get started my first question has
to do with one of the subheadings I
found in your book it caught my
attention it read Better Living Through
effective writing first I'd love for you
to Define what you mean by effective
writing and second How does writing well
help us live better I love this question
because I think it is not initially
obvious so writing better means making
it easier for readers and the reason
this improves everyone's lives is
because it saves readers time and it's
Kinder writing effectively make it easy
for busy readers to navigate what we
send them pull out the key information
and do what they are planning to do
anyway which is move on to the next
thing and so it's more effective for us
and it's kinder to readers one thing
that is very different about the way you
approach your thoughts on writing is
that you focus on the reader many others
focus on what is actually written why is
focusing on the reader so important and
what role does the reader's context play
in how we write for
them I think you're right that a lot of
the way we think about writing is as if
there are some idealized form of writing
well is the way you were taught to write
in high school and
college and that successful writing what
my co-author on a lot of this work
including our book and I have come to
believe is that writing well is very
different than writing
effectively and we should focus on how
do we write effectively and what that
means is we should write in a way that
reflects the way people actually read
and in the world busy people are just
constantly skimming no one cares about
our writing as much as we do and the
default behavior when reading is to move
on and Skip so we need to write in a way
that reflects and accommodate the real
it that people are skimming what we
write I agree I skim all the time
sometimes that gets me in trouble what
looks different in our writing what
actually tactically in terms of the
sentence structure the words we use
what's different when you're writing for
people who skim versus people who are
trying to demonstrate they actually did
their homework in a class right so when
someone is skimming they are jumping
around they are trying to pull out not
linearly they're just trying to jump
around figure out what's this about do I
need to do something and when can I move
on and so when we watch with eye
tracking we see the people Dart around
and they try to get the gist of what
we're saying without reading a closely
so what that means is we want to add
structure one of our six principles is
design for navigation make it easy to
design what we write for readers so add
headings add structure so that a reader
who jumps around can easily figure out
what what's going on and then need the
the key points are up top what what this
contains so they can Orient themselves
they can jump around using headings that
you can use formatting to draw attention
to the key information but in addition
to writing complete sentences that flow
from one set the next and have active
verbs we also need to write in a way
that just reflects the reality that our
readers are jumping around when they
read and so that means writing was
structure well you're preaching to the
choir here and part of the reason I
think you and I get along so well is we
both believe very strongly in structure
and when I was doing research for the
new book I have coming out I spoke with
somebody who works for the dummies
organization all those dummies books and
she talked to me about wayfinding how
when you write you need to think about
helping people find their way through
your content and that's what I heard you
just talking about that structure helps
people find their way in terms of what
it is they're specifically looking for
and I think that's so important and
thank you for highlighting that
you mentioned that your book has six
principles that can help busy readers I
love that your principles are based on
academic social science research I think
that's so important can you pick two
other principles Beyond structure that
you believe are really important and can
you give us some concrete advice on how
to apply those sure so what is less is
more and we have run lots and lots of
randomized experiments that have
something like this structure we an
experiment with a large political
organization where he wrote a
fundraising email that was six
paragraphs in one condition with 350,000
people they got the full fundraising
message in the other condition we
deleted every other paragraph
arbitrarily people read them both and
thought it was incoherent in the shorter
one because we did arbitrarily deleted
paragraphs and yet the three paragraph
one raised more money than the longer
one one even though was incoherent just
less is more both in omitting needless
words that's easy of course if words are
actually needless cut them great the
harder choices are
omitting useful but not necessary words
or useful but not necessary ideas and
the idea is just the more you keep the
less likely it is that someone will read
and respond to our message so there's
not a right answer to how much to keep
we just need to know those train offs
the more you add the less likely people
are to read and engage but if they do
they're going to get more content so
fewer words but also let not not just
needless words also sometimes we have to
make judgment calls where we eliminate
useful detail that would just deter or
distract from our core point so it seems
to me that we have to be very mindful of
of what we write and think about the
reader perspective I think a lot of us
are under such pressure just to get
ideas down that we don't really think
about prioritizing what's important for
the reader and making those tradeoffs
you talked about before I ask you to
share one more of your principles how
much does word choice play into this I
mean sometimes I read things where
people I think are purposely trying to
impress me with their vocabulary when in
fact I think simpler might be better so
less is more I also think simpler
language use might be better what do you
think
the second principle I might share is
that make reading easy that means short
Comet words short sentences simple
grammar and the idea here is that it is
easier to read writing that is written
in this way so it requires less effort
it's less taxing it's more pleasant easy
and fast to read additionally it's
accessible to more people so this is a
second point and add addition to just
being more likely to be read and
responded to it also is more accessible
and inclusive so the median us adult
reads at a ninth grade reading level
very often when we write these sentences
they're complex they're complete they're
beautifully written with flowing Pros
but they're they're kind of inaccessible
to a large chunk of potential readers
and one of my favorite Parts about
writing the book and I imagine you had
the same experience writing your book
book I love learning about this
literature that I had never encountered
before one of these huge areas of
research is on ey tracking how people's
eyes move when they read and if you can
get people to read actually attentively
carefully read which is rarely the way
we actually read but if you get people
to read like that what you see is they
go word word word word period and then
at the period they paused for the period
Cause effect and they sit there making
it as if they are making sense of did I
get the whole idea and if they didn't
they go backwards and they jump
backwards and reread that's a pain it's
cognitively difficult it requires effort
it makes people less likely to continue
given that everyone especially if it's
kind of practical writing text email
reports pitches they got lots of things
in their queue and so the easier we make
the reading the faster it is they'll it
it'll be for the reader to get through
and the more accessible it'll be to more
people I love that ey tracking Behavior
that's fascinating to me thank you for
sharing that I had never thought about
that but sure you can actually measure
if we're making it difficult I have two
follow-up questions if you'll allow me
Todd one it strikes me that if I write
in a way that is easier for my reader to
digest that I am actually making that
experience a little more pleasant for
them they're not as frustrated how does
emotion play in what you write I can
imagine that if I write something that
the material I'm covering is emotional
in nature that can be helpful in some
ways right because people are engaging
in a different way but also their
experience of reading might bring about
an emotion as well I mean I remember
back in high school when I was having to
read texts that I was not that
interested in I got frustrated when I
was reading I'm not going to mention any
books because I don't want anybody to
see what I found offensive but what are
your thoughts on that the kinds of
writing that I'm mainly the justess so
this book is co-author with my longtime
co-author Jessica gasy Fang and the kind
of writing that we're really focused on
and this all originated with advising
organization leaders during the pandemic
communicating to their stakeholders and
employees and constituents is practical
writing when we are writing to our
families by text or to our colleagues by
email or slack or in sales proposals to
potential clients or current clients
it's practical writing and so so it's
not going to be
the literature that we sometimes
associate with when we think of good
writing so how do we write practical
writing that said there are ways to be
more persuasive and more compelling all
of that is conditional or rather
requires that people are paying
attention and so I have spent the last
20 years developing interventions to
increase people's likelihood of voting
or increase people's likelihood of
choosing healthy foods or increasing
students likely to going to school by
communicating with famili and all those
are these interventions in the field to
change behaviors what I only recently
realized is that stage zero what
perceived all of the persuasion and
Behavioral Science that I and my
colleagues have been developing is do
they pay any attention to what we're
sending them to our
Communications and very often if it's
very dense they just don't bother
engaging at all or if they do engage
they engage superficially before just
moving on and say I'll get back to that
later and so for me the the big context
is how do we get to the before we can be
emotionally evocative or persuasive or
structure things using different kinds
of framing we need to write away that
people will engage and process deeply
enough to even get our messages through
I want to come back to this question of
Engagement because I think it's very
critical but before I do you said
writing simply and you us structure can
help do you have data or an opinion on
the use of lists and bullet points
because at one level a list in bullet
points to me appears structured and it
in many ways is simpler than Pros with
subjects nouns Etc but I also know that
processing lists can be hard for people
what's your take on bullet points and
lists to help people read what's written
better assuming that they are used to
organize related ideas I think lists are
fantastic like bullet points for example
so typically there is an agreed upon
meaning of bullets we all agree that if
there is a sentence and then a bunch of
bullet points that each of the bull
points resembles each other in some way
in some kind and that they are all
related to the preceding sentence and so
that licenses the reader if they
understand what the preceding sentence
was to just skip the bullets if they
don't if it's not relevant to them but
it also tells them that each bullet is
an independent idea and that they're
distin again the goal through everything
is how do we make it easier for the
readers to navigate and understand what
we're trying to convey you have changed
my perspective so thank you for that I
have actively dissuaded people from
using bullet points and lists but I see
their value in a written form I still
think I hold my position that when
you're speaking and you're putting a
slide up behind you that lists can be
challenging for your audience so I
appreciate the balance we have to find
of leveraging visual structure through
bullet points and lists without going
overboard and doing too much which
brings me back to the idea that you
mentioned just a bit ago around
engagement I'd love for you to talk
about how readers choose to engage or
not with writing and give me
specifically some techniques that
writers can use to increase a reader's
engagement I gave a talk today at an
academic cerence where I open with raise
your hand if you've ever received a text
message and you looked at it and it was
and you're like I can't deal with this
now and you postpone dealing with it and
everyone's hand us up and then I said
keep your hand up if it has ever
happened that you didn't get back to it
and everyone's hand stays up right which
is in that the shortest mode of
communication that's possible which is
our text messages even though as people
look at I just can't deal with that
that's the first version of
disengagement which is not even
processing it at all or figure out what
it's about that's like the first version
of not engaging at all the second stage
is when you're reading How Deeply you
engage versus like do you really read
sentence by sentence or are you darting
around and very often it's just darting
around and so there are strategies can
use that a lot of it as influence and
Behavioral Science on increasing
people's interest or personal relevance
of content or the pleasure they get in
the language use but for us starting
point is let's just make it as easy as
possible for the reader to leave the
message with the key information we're
trying to conve and from there then we
can start to leverage these other tools
of Social and Behavioral Science so we
just got to get them to focus and pay
attention so this breeds another
question obviously this isn't
appropriate for all writing what role do
icons emoticons emojis have because in
some ways those are engaging I will look
at a text that has emojis in it in a
different way than one that's that just
have words do you have a position on
that is a research behind that I love
the phrase do you have a position on it
the only thing ma Jes and I have a
position on is that our readers are busy
and we need to write in a way that makes
it as easy for them to read what we are
sending them as possible that will be
most effective for us in achieving our
goals as writers and it's also Kinder by
saving them time that said there's been
a bunch of research on emojis that I
think is really fun one there are lots
of Courts federal state International
courts that have ruled on the meaning of
emojis in financial documents and wee
wouldn't surprise you if I told you that
a bunch of crypto
Communications sometimes involves emojis
and cour to tried to interpret what
those mean as contractually binding or
not that's interesting enough but here's
the most interesting thing there are
surveys showing that different
Generations me being a middle-aged Guy
versus my kids will interpret the same
emojis meaning something different so a
smiley face to
me means warm feeling
probably agreement maybe humor and to my
13-year-old daughter a smiley face means
sarcasm and irony and so even just those
kind of generational differences mean
wow emojis are dangerous for clarity
because they are interpreted different
ways by different people that's just
generational you can imagine different
people have different meanings for
different emojis so I think they have a
place as long as you know your audience
and they are unambiguously both
appropriate meaning they somehow fit the
Norms of your organization and you
confidence that it can be interpreted
the way you think it is I give you a
thumbs up emoji on that answer and to me
that means a good answer I think the
jury is still out literally and
figuratively so thank you you mentioned
norms and I want to dig into that you
talk in your book about Norms status and
identity what do you mean by this and
why does it even matter for the writing
that we do we are most effective when we
make it easy for a reader to read what
we were sending them and one of the
things we talked about is using fewer
words fewer ideas shorter another is
writing simply another is designing it
adding structures soent wayfinding
throughout the writing like navigation
those are generally true but different
people in different contexts with
different Norms have different
expectations on them when they write so
when there are a bunch of State
Department emails that were released
where lower status people writing up
wrote longer more indirect messages
whereas higher status people
communicating down were shorter and more
direct if you are lower status there's a
lot of like defensive writing where
you're not sure how you're going to be
interpreted you are very concerned about
how you're going to be understood and
what people are going to think of you so
you as a writer any person listening has
to really navigate the unequal burdens
on writers and the way we are
interpreted but the thing that is
universally true is that the person you
are writing to is busy and probably
skimming and so you want to make it as
easy as possible for them one thing that
I teach when I teach with leaders about
how to communicate and I think this will
resonate with you having read your book
that one thing leaders can do is set
norms for how do we communicate yeah and
in the US Army there is a regulation an
actual codified regulation uh called
Bluff bottom line up front in EN listed
person writing to a general bottom line
up front first sentence is the bottom
line a general writing down to an
enlisted person bottom line up tront
first sentage is the bottom line and by
making that a rule and a norm in the
organization it is easier for writers to
make sure that they're effective it's
easier for readers because they know
exactly where to get the bottom line and
it also protects the lower status people
from the kind of burden of navigating
ambiguous concerns about how they're
going to be interpreted and so as
Leaders we just set the Norms to make it
more effective and also protect the
lower status rers that point is so
critical and one I think all of us
should think about in the roles we serve
in organizations what's important is the
information we convey but we can also
help set the norms and expectations for
what that communication should should
look like and read like and I don't
think many organizations do that save
maybe the military or some governmental
agency or something highly regulated I
think that's a wonderful idea I I often
encourage the organizations I consult to
think about their communication
infrastructure and I'm talking about do
you use email versus slack versus
texting for certain things I think they
should add to that this notion of what
makes for good writing and how can we
make it easier on the people who are
doing the reading so thank you so Todd
before we end I'd like to ask you a
series of questions two of them are
similar across all our guests and then I
have one random question I'm going to
ask are you up for that let's do it all
right let's start with the random
question first what is a pet peeve of
yours that bothers you in the writing
that you see of people writing can serve
at least two purposes one is clarifying
our
thinking and the other is communicate
that magical idea of getting an idea
from my head into your head without us
directly interacting right that's such
what is Magic but the first one is also
helping us clarify our own thinking and
I think what can be frustrating as a
reader is if people don't realize those
are two separate things and when they're
writing they write starting wherever
they thought they were starting and
ending in a different place and at the
end is where they really want the key
message to get cross to me and it would
probably be better if they if they took
the perspective how do I make it easier
for the reader the reader doesn't need
to know where you started the reader
needs to know what the key information
and those are two different functions
and editing and revising is the key to
getting from the first to the second
well put my pet peeve is along those
lines it's people who start from an
assumption that you're where they're at
it's that curse of knowledge and that
really can be frustrating and sometimes
very intimidating so question number two
and you can take this as any type of
communic unication written spoken Etc
who is a communicator that you admire
and why I'm going to take this I think a
direction others had not I really like
the approach of Don Norman who is the
founder of user Center design and wrote
a book called the Design of Everyday
things and I'm not talking about his
writing though he's
prolific his like basic philosophy is if
you've designed an object and the user
interacts with it and does not
understand how to use it
it's on you the desire it's
never the user's fault it's always the
designer's fault and that that design is
a form of communication and Jesse and I
have that basic philosophy when it comes
to writing practical writing even if my
writing is super clear and if you had
read the whole thing you'd understand
why we're doing this what time it is
where it's happening and what you're
supposed to bring if I send it to you
and you don't pull those information
pieces from it that's on me not on you
it's the right always on the writer to
make sure it gets through to the busy
reader and it's not just about Clarity
it's about actually accommodating the
fact of this person that our readers are
busy and skimming very important the
design of your messages matters final
question what are the first three
ingredients that go into a successful
communication recipe three things goal
context and revising goal we have to
know what we're trying to accomplish and
maybe writing can help us figure that
out but we have to be super clear on our
goal and then from there we write then
we have to know our context what are the
Norms what are the expectations how are
we going to be
interpreted how much detail is expected
of us or needed or wanted and then
revising is applying the six principles
of writing for busy people which we
talked about three of them but so it's
Clarity goal knowing your context and
revising unfortunately all of them are
hard but necessary but necessary in the
work I do around oral communication
speaking they're identical this notion
of iteration is critical and it's a
process many of us just think I got to
get it out and it's done but it's
actually an iterative process and I
appreciate that as do I appreciate this
whole conversation Todd you certainly
didn't disappoint your information was
very valuable allow me to structure it
clearly point one people are busy right
to make it easier for them point two we
have to consider the context when we
write and context includes Norms status
Etc and point three learning to write
better is something that you can do and
it's worth the effort Todd thank you so
much I wish you well on all that you do
especially with your book writing for
busy readers communicate more
effectively in the real world thank you
thank you
[Applause]
Matt thanks for joining us for another
episode of think fast talk smart the
podcast from Stanford Graduate School of
Business this episode was produced by
Jenny Luna Ryan Campos and me Matt
Abrahams our music was provided by Floyd
Wonder for more information and episodes
find us on YouTube or wherever you get
your podcasts thank you and please make
sure to subscribe and follow us on
LinkedIn